I played the yearly Robert arena in
2019. WoW
I'm only about four hours late
four hours late
so that was an eight hour tournament
this is also an eight hour tournament
this time I'm only
two and a half hours late
I feel like I'm improving
maybe in a few years I'll be on time
let's see this poll
wow
58 42 percent Zen mode it is okay I'm
joining
welcome to more people
if this goes on YouTube in the future
uh I'll be time stamping every game so
feel free to let me know what your
favorite game is
assuming I play more than one game
am I gonna play root chess we played in
Abu Dhabi actually
uh we had a really hard fought game
there
but it takes a moment for the
oh I okay I don't know who I'm playing I
could be playing Roo chess I could be
playing like um
beginner I could be playing Magnus
Carlsen I have no idea
oh E4 I'll play E4
oh thank you Peter Holland
appreciate that
okay we have appearance
against the period so I might actually
transpose into the line where I play
Bishop F4
okay this is actually a modern so it's a
little bit different
um black hasn't committed to Knight F6
and against this move order I like to
play an F3
expecting Bishop G7
oh that's an interesting move order
because normally I like to play Bishop
C4 Queen E2
but the Knight coming to F6 kinda
provokes Knight C3
I could play the setup with Bishop
Bishop D3
I'll play Bishop D3
this is a more solid setup
welcome back to Seth Andreas Max Tori
and vlads
hi Eric duck free stream
yeah the stream could very well be duck
free
uh time's a castle so the point of the
bishop on D3 is I I defend the pawn
with the bishop so I don't have to play
Knight C3 and
um in this side level I play Pawn Z3 and
I get the pawn chain against the fiend
Bishop which generally is a good thing
undermine the bishop
and then very often the Knight will go
to D2 maybe in maneuver to F1 and
someday enter the game
and Bishop G4 is respectable
yeah I'll play Knight D2
I'm essentially preparing H3 because in
the event of takes I want to take back
with Knight
I might also want to bring the queen 900
days of amazing content I have a request
Herrick if possible can you play with
the Amazon piece the Amazon I'm not sure
if there is a chess equivalent that lets
you play with it
uh please elaborate I don't think I've
heard of the Amazon piece
I love your username
I'm a cup of tea
actually I just made tea it's um some
nice oolong
oolong tea that A friend gave to me
so neither four is one intention
so I'll start with rookie one
let's go Eric first place let's go
so Zen mode hides the standings so I
don't know what first place has
but I mean this is my first game of the
tournament
I I late joined a few hours late so
probably far behind first place
currently
I actually tied for last place
okay so F5 is is the first sign that my
opponent
is not Magnus Carlson
because I have Queen B3
and I think I'm winning a pawn
I mean up until up until maybe Knight H5
it could have been Magnus Amazon equals
Queen plus Knight
oh the quite
oh then maybe you didn't see my stream
yesterday
I played I played jumbo chess
with like so many new pieces including a
camel
and the Canuck
and I mean there are so many others
but uh at some point I'll get back to
the variants
I'm trying to keep a balance between all
the fun
new variants that are popping up and
just classic normal chests
because classic normal chess is also fun
especially when you can get positions
like this
no mercy now
13 months pogba's good luck Eric
think you're a random oven
and Mr Swift tickle do you have
recommended brand of tea for those of us
coffee folk who have only ever drank
sheep tea boiled in a hole in the ground
cheap tea boiled in a hole in the ground
oh dear
where'd you even find that
um there's actually a a new tea brand
I was introduced to recently
um
now I've been super impressed with a
friend of mine gave me uh a gift of of
one of their most popular teas it was
like a Japanese sencha tea
um imported from Japan
I can share the website
uh if I can find it it's called uproots
t
and they they don't have like too many
options
but as far as I can tell like the
options that they do have are super high
quality it's all loose leaf they sell
like strainers too
happy birthday
oh no my quack
oh thank you mapper happy one year
I'm not sure what ELO to guess in this
game
I mean
my opponent really just made okay maybe
a couple mistakes like F5 and Rook F7
so I'd probably say below 1500
but probably in the range of like 13 to
1700
okay it's debating how to capture The
Rook or weather I mean there are so many
ways to open
the bishop was getting trapped
well let's say let's say 14
01 let's see
53.
853 I was taking the opening so
seriously too
like this opening Magnus Carlson could
easily play
just a modern Bishop G4 makes sense too
before I play H3
oh that's kind of funny
analysis
I mean yeah this this was actually
following like Carlson games
C3 we were following aroni and Carlson
Knight H5 still played by a couple
Masters
but then F5 yeah lulled generally this
Pawn should you should be very careful
moving this Pawn
[Music]
um
if you're castled even if you're not
castled like that pawn it's it's a risky
Pawn to move and this diagonal was
clearly exploitable
so
I think more often blocks should go for
like Knight D7 E5 and then if I play D5
then F5 is more Justified
anyway back to tournament
Zen mode will stay on
so I have two tournament points
the leader has 65.
so I have some work to do
foreign
got a coffee sponsorship with his own
flavor any chance you might get a tea
sponsorship like that in the future
um
Maybe
I'm actually I'm in touch with the
founder of this website
I haven't like really talked in detail
about it would be cool to have some sort
of partnership with uproots tea
but I'm super selective when it comes to
working with various Brands and I want
to make sure they're
quality products that I would use myself
okay
um
can't believe my appointment was 8 53
that last game
side I was 600 points off
okay this game
my opponent could be Beth Harmon
playing a Queen's Gambit
Bishop G5
I think I'll go for a Cambridge Springs
it's an opening that um has been in my
Arsenal over the years
I actually don't play it too often
online these days but
I think it's a very simple opening
um to learn especially if you're
looking for a response to like Mainline
Queen's gambits
now with this move my opponent is
actually preventing Cambridge Springs
because usually
uh if the pawns were still here then
Queen A5 would be the idea
and there'd be pressure against the
bishop this position Queen A5 I don't
think is as effective
because this Pawn is not removing itself
from the fifth rank
so
uh so I basically have to just go for
the standard plans of a Carlsbad
structure
and this is essentially uh the Queen's
Gambit exchange variation
so Rook E8 my usual go-to plan is Knight
f8 Knight G6
and this is just the first step of the
plan
the next step after Knight G6 will be to
play this and then each six
and then provoke the trade
of Bishop for Knights
will you be coming to India
sometime
um I wanted to go to India during
Olympian
a few months ago but it was just too
complicated
I'm sure I'll make it to India someday
I mean hopefully within the next maybe
five years
so more often
um
at least when I play strong players in
this line The Rook goes to B1 to support
the minority attack with B4 B5
here white is going for something I
don't think I've ever seen before on
each horror that's interesting
I mean this is not really a threat
I'm trying to figure out how to deal
with this
because the usual move Bishop D6 runs
into H5 so the Knight is pinned
I mean I could play
Bishop G4 because there's no H3
but Bishop G4 I'm not sure about Knight
T2 and then F3
hmm
there's also this move which is
interesting
if I play Knight H5
I'm essentially
provoking the trade
so Bishop takes E7 Queen E7 and then G3
would be expected
and then I'm wondering if there's any
potential sacrifice
like Knight G3 fg3 Queen E3
but then Queen F no queen of two hangs a
bishop
King G2
that seems close I mean there's
a lot of attacking potential
Knight H5 takes takes G3
I have Bishop H3 immediately on Bishop
G4
with Bishop g492 Knight G3 so Bishop G4
Knight D2 Knight G3 fg3
takes
and then the queen is cut off but then
King G2
King G2 can I sack the Knight again Pawn
takes Queen H3
King G1 rookie 3 hitting the bishop and
threatening Rook G3
I'm just going into probably some
unnecessary deep lines
it seems like there's a lot of potential
I'm not seeing like a crystal clear
knockout blow
but looks like there's
there should be a lot of concerns for
whites
and this H4 move it does it did
reinforce the bishop but it kind of
softens the king side
and I think it makes sense to
try and organize some attack
yeah so now I'm threatening this Pawn
although maybe we could trade H pawns
maybe not
okay yeah so I was looking at Bishop G4
that's so tempting to sack here
I think I'll start with Bishop G4
I'm just realizing there's Bishop E2
though
and then I suck
I mean Bishop B2 is already some success
to make the bishop more passive
it's hard to gauge my opponent's rating
like I would think
below 2200 because of this H4 move
but apart from that White's been playing
very naturally
maybe two makes sense
I really want to take on G3
I mean this position maybe just calls
for more gradual patient play
Queen
F6
kind of like this move
the problem is Queen F6 Knight D2 we
trade
I have a feeling at some point I'm gonna
sack a piece somewhere
okay building up pressure
the downside of this move is that now
this Knight is a bit more stuck
can't easily return to F6
Queen D1 okay
and queen F5
opponent's playing quickly I gotta just
up the tempo
in Queen F5
just so the Knight can come back
okay so now the bishop and queen are
tied down to the knights I mean there's
a lot of tension with the diagonal
and if the Knight moves and the tension
will be relieved like Knight T2 we trade
a knight could take
I'm fantasizing about like Rook lifting
and sacking and mating
still very far away though
rookie one
yeah I think I should just move it back
the only reason for the Knight to be on
H5 was the sack and
I don't think that's like that was so
realistic
it's better to have access to the square
this does open up the queen
maybe come and create a battery
I mean white is clearly a little bit
passive here
it's a strategy for white is probably to
trade but
I mean to trade you basically have to
retreat the Knight
which we see
okay I have to take
yeah it feels a little bit better for
black but probably still takes a lot of
work
and white white is relatively solid like
this Knight's restricted
any night move into White's territory
just
just gets captured pretty much
like 94 is an option
we trade I think I'm better off just
gradually improving the Rooks
waiting for some opportunity
I just have to play quicker too
yeah so far I'd probably guess between
2000 and 2200
could be higher though I mean it could
be like 2300
it could also be lower
I think my opponent's rating is anywhere
between like 1600 to 2300
just a lot of natural moves from lights
I mean no obvious blunders
um Queen H3 now
I mean if White's not careful this could
go really wrong really quickly for
whites
especially with the queen here
but to be honest I don't see if I even
have a threat
like I want to play this but I don't
want to trade
maybe like a plan long term of like G5
could be something
maybe The Rook should be on E6
okay one wants to play this
so now it's a question can I get away
with this
which I think I can
it kind of looks weird because I'm
trapping my own Queen
but Knight G5 allows Queen H2
the out lights just going for this move
I really want to play this
because Knight can't take because I meet
if Pawn takes
and then you Rook
could that work
wait so takes takes rookie six
that's crazy if it works
when Queen F1 doesn't work
like why is this kind of tied down how
does white get out of that and
threatening Rook G6
I think I'm gonna try it
I might just be completely over pushing
but I don't see how light untangles
it feels slow like my plan is this this
and then move the Knight somewhere
uh so White's gonna have two moves to
try and defend
now of course if Knight takes I was made
in two
um but the the key
issue for white is that the queen is
tied down to the Knight and the Knight
is tied down to H2
and the King has no moves
so I I don't see what white does here
oppong has some time to think
yeah this um allows me to win back the
knights
okay so that was a success
I sacked a piece temporarily but I won
I want to pawn in the process
and now I still have an attack
how to maximize this Rook H6
Queen G2 I'm thinking
Queen F5
I don't want the queen trade I just want
to keep Queens on the board and
eventually meet
a good move
say this
now I'm up two Pawns
I actually I really haven't been looking
at chat for the last few minutes so
apologies if I'm ignoring anyone but
sometimes I'll
get very invested in these games
let's play this
idea Rook F2
and still plenty of time there's no
increments but um
yeah white is
about to lose more material
I'm gonna win F2 or the queen or both
I want to take I guess I do
okay
now it's time to
play Blitz
and take more free stuff
I'm guessing like 2100
does my opponent like managed the time
very well played very quickly
and the I think the mistake from White
was not obvious this game
let's see
1702 wow I over Gus I've been over
guessing a lot
at least I was only 400 points off
rather than 600 points
um yeah it was good quality game though
because what was a mistake from White
I think maybe Queen C2 was
was a bit wrong just allowing my queen
to infiltrate
uh Knight F3 was also wrong
and queen E2
and Knight H4
yeah 94 was a cool tactical idea it's
the only winning move for back
I have to play it right away because
otherwise I'd give time for white to
play Queen of fun
Eric hey our Beasley welcome back thanks
for subbing
yeah so if you're just joining um that
was my second game of the
yearly rapid Arena
I have a feeling I'm going to play a lot
of games of stream
and I've decided before the tournament
that every game I will play in Zen mode
so I won't know my opponents
ratings
and it's kind of like a live guess ELO
I've really been over guessing but I
think my opponent's thus far have played
better than their actual strength
okay
and maybe I'll play a little bit more
aggressively
yeah we have a fill door I'll play a um
just the main line
yeah there's a few different setups
you can go for here
let's start with Bishop C4
it is very natural
[Music]
just Castle quickly
I'm pretty sure A4
if not played here it's played at some
point
there's also Bishop B3
I think I'll play Bishop B3 there's
ideas for black to storm
although maybe A4 makes sense skin space
I'll play 84. it gives the bishop some
room to retreat
and there's ideas of A5
not sure if Asics accomplishes that much
because B5 is still off limits because
they take and there's a pin
just debating how to
proceed here
there's a question what setup I want the
bishop
could throw in A5 say like F3 Bishop E3
foreign
like B6 Bishop B7
so maybe
hmm
I should really not overthink this
there's also H3 Bishop E3
and that way I discouraged Knight G4
is Bishop E3 right away there's Knight
G4 which is sometimes annoying
there's probably a lot of acceptable
moves
I think the key is not to overthink and
just to
like play a a solid setup
yeah Bishop B3
now it's actually really nice that the
square is off limits because F4
will come and attack the knights
and if there's no 9g4 then the Knight
might have to go back to G6
and then there's some play on the pawn
storming
also some idea another five
oh
okay it was very good that I played A4
because otherwise if my Pawn was still
here and my Bishop would be getting
trapped
now it's a question do I want to play 95
allow the trade allow C4 Bishop A2
that's kind of annoying I could also
just play this move
I like this move a little bit better
there's one thing to understand about
this position is white has a little bit
more space
because I have the the more advanced
Center Pawn
so I probably don't want to allow trades
of minor pieces
and especially with C4 coming
um I'll be ready to play F4
I'm actually not sure if C4 is like even
that great for black
because C4 Bishop A2 and then F4 is
already a threat
oh I'm spending a little bit of time in
the opening but um
I think it's it's worth it to ensure I'm
not making any careless mistakes
have a clear plan
another reason why I played H3 earlier
not F3 was because of this exact idea
very often it's nice for like taking
space
so Bishop E6
and now I have a decision because I
could trade
I could also play F4 immediately
uh F4 immediately and then if takes I
take the Knight
yeah let's play F4
there's Knight C4
hitting the bishop
and the pong
which maybe I should have been aware of
yeah I'm sorry I see the duck emotes in
chat
and duck chess will have to wait until
maybe a little bit later
by hoping that people still appreciate
normal chess
the goal is to to still be instructional
teach a thing or two
and hopefully when I do end up playing
duck chess
people will appreciate it a little bit
more
I I can't just do it all the time and
and spoil everyone
look at all these ducky emotes if you're
watching on YouTube this is what you're
missing in twitch chat
okay I'm up on time
opponent has a decision to make
there's a few possible Night Moves
I mean one calculation is Knight C4
Bishop C1
and that's kind of weird
Knight C6 is normal
so I could take
there's cases where I don't mind the
trade and double b-pongs
but I think I'm better off taking
[Music]
actually if I take take the box already
preparing D5
if I don't take then this move can come
I have an interesting idea here to play
F5 it looks very anti-positional
but it's kind of a mix of
following principles and disobeying
principles
uh let's play F5
I'll try and explain this move
uh yeah let's not run
I should explain
um we have to cancel this prediction
though it's too easy just to cheat and
and see the rating of my opponent
um
so I don't wanna have people like Chi
and just steal Channel points
uh I don't know how to cancel the
prediction though
or maybe maybe some mod knows how
yeah unfortunately we can't really do
predictions for live guests ELO
[Music]
I'm sure most people follow the honor
System but
what to do
I would probably be very bad at
predicting
I've been so off today
I appreciate the effort though
I guess we could run a poll
with running a poll then there's nothing
on the line and then we get some like
honest feedback
I mean so far my opponent's reading I
feel like is like above 1800
I'm gonna play G4
I should elaborate on what I was saying
earlier because with this F5 move
um it's following principles in the
sense that because I have a dark Square
Bishop my pawns should be on light
squares
and that way I maximize just the number
of squares I can I can control
um the downside of F5 is I leave this
Pawn backwards I really weaken the
square and the Knight didn't choose to
go here
but this Pawn could be a Target on the
half of in file
I'm debating between this and this
I like Knight G3 reinforcing the pawn
hey Eric when are you back in Germany
want to show you a losing opening
oh
uh yeah I've been to Germany a few times
in my life
but
I don't know the next time I'll be back
I mean hopefully sometime in 2023
I know there's a pretty large chassis in
there
now I guess I have incentive to visit
too to see what this magical losing
opening is
okay so my pawns are kind of stuck
you just Queen D2 idea G5
yeah the square is in box control
I gotta move faster
and get away with G5 right away
I think it's okay
each word can follow
it's getting sharp
I mean now there's looming ideas of F6
now I have to be really careful about
the fork potential
it's so important that this Rook is
guarding F3
in Knight D3 it looks scary but
I think it's harmless
it's like a Halloween decoration
yeah there's a lot of attacking ideas
for lights I mean with
just with the potential Pawn breaks
the square
there's even some Rook lift
probably not likely also Knight H5
also realizing the queen can kind of
slide over to G2
and then align with the King
and then maybe there's potential for
Knight H5 and I have six
or Knight H5 Pawn F6
like box found two Outpost swears for
the knights
but for the time being they're basically
Halloween decorations
F6 is interesting so that prevents me
from playing F6
it gives me some options
I think I'll play H4
to reinforce
and now the silence open
not so easy to exploit though
thank you Potato Man
converting from Prime to tier one
appreciate that
I really haven't given like a
specific guess of my opponent's ELO
I've been over guessing a lot I really
think my bones over two thousand
and clearer like positional
understanding and handle the opening
while
okay question how to attack
maybe bishop F4
I was 95
actually I kind of like King G2
because now this file is half open
the king is now on a square where it
can't get Fort the Knight can't for king
and queen
and the prospects I mean it might be a
slow plan but the prospect of doubling
up on each file
could be very nice
because this Pawn doesn't have too many
Defenders apart from the King
up over a minute now
it's just hard for black to find a move
like the pieces are are kind of stuck
and there's not a clear plan
and positions like this are like it's
very easy to just blunder as black
like trying to
just search for something
I'm actually liking the fact that this
plan is slow because
like the next three or four moves for
lock are really not so clear
I might just be winning this game on
time
it's interesting that it's like it's
equal material
seems like a tense position but
uh yeah I'm about to win like pretty
easily I think
hopefully I don't jinx myself
let's improve the bishop
Rook H4 on the horizon
I'm curious what the engine would give
like in this position or maybe a few
moves ago
um yeah I have six traps of Bishop
okay I'm guessing
2020 how about
opponents reading
uh I think those Works actually Rook F2
I take it
let's see
1735 appointment played well I mean just
was kind of slow towards the end there
I think my guesses have been getting
closer every game
I was 20 20 a bad year
it was a decent year for chess content
hindsight 1735 yeah good luck in the
tournament Eric oh thank you pelo vatana
thank you ordinary otter
do others quack hello Eric also quack I
guess they do
okay real quick
analysis board
how good was the position
saying I blend engine's saying I'm worse
here wow
oh D5
it's not an easy move to play because it
allows E5
but I guess the point is Pawn D4
there's some
counter play for lock because if here I
take the Knight just Bishop takes
and then
yeah like already after G5 weights
clearly better
King G2 is nice
okay nice game
oh there's a question from tafasca
when I analyze 905 after Knight t7
ah in this position
oh Knight of five top engine move it's
probably good
um yeah I guess by the five I'd probably
imagine 95 or Knight C5
I guess the point is to just get the
bishop here
so I probably should have considered
it seems counterintuitive to
trade off blocks dark Square Bishop
which has no legal moves
but the point is that
long-term
the two Bishops are really nice for
whites
Bishop E2 restricting the knights
especially the dark part Bishop can do
some damage
remember back in the day where four
player chis helped set a collab up
between you agamater Levy and Hikaru for
a four-player game I do you're another
admin can help you out getting to learn
the different variants and to maybe set
up Arenas your wdcc in making
wdcc world
duck
oh World duck chess champion
yeah it'd be cool to get in touch with
admins to like have
to just find out how the variant
determines work
it seems like they're they're somewhat
scarce but it would be cool to do like a
viewer variant tournament or viewer duck
tournaments
can we have some unofficial or official
World duck championship
okay
again I don't know my opponents
uh
I gotta have at least one staffer gamut
though right
let's go for a stop right now
I'm not the highest rated player in Duck
chess
um now there's a few people above me I
think I'm I'm still probably top five
okay Stafford Gambit time
oh opponent played that quickly opponent
is playing really quickly
I'm playing quickly too because this is
still theory for me hey Eric greetings
from Newfoundland
oh greetings from St Louis
thank you Scooby-Doo
okay hitting the pawn on E3
it's good to see my opponent taking more
time here
there's not too many ways to defend the
pawn
foreign
I've shown this probably a handful of
times like this exact position
in various staffer Gambit videos
the the most popular move is King D2 one
of the only ways to defend the pawn
um Knight D2 I don't know if I've ever
encountered before
that looks like a really risky move for
white
because I have this move
which I think I'll play
I'm Bishop G4 on the horizon
and the beauty of the Knight here is it
prevents
[Music]
except I'd probably be happy if like a
castle because in Bishop G4
camera C1 was expected
yeah Bishop G4 actually runs into Queen
G3
I'm not sure if I'm winning anything
here
I mean I've won the pawn back so it's
already some opening success
I think I might just take the bishop and
play this it looks weird to trade off my
Giga night for this sad
F1 Bishop
but
the Giga Knight could become stuck
just a little bit
I'm number four in Duck chess ooh
I'll have to grind the duck chest later
I shouldn't overthink this I think I'll
take
man I could play Bishop
spend one moment on Bishop E6
because H4
and then Queen C5 and then Knight B3
and queen B6 and Bishop E2
I can also take on C2 and some lines
this is just simpler
now because both Rooks have moved white
cannot Castle
maybe white can fake Castle
if I can draw arrows
but I'm very very much ready to real
castle
thank you super Super Robot ax
okay upon the taking time
this Pawn looks hanging but it's kind of
poisonous
okay now it's definitely not hanging
castling Queen side is still illegal
because the Rook has moved hey Eric I'm
loving the polo looks amazing
shout out to Lululemon
maybe someday they'll sponsor me
welcome back to Damien
okay I want to attack another Pawn
I think I'll play
I'll play Queen E5
as if white plays C3 and then I can play
C5
and essentially
create a weakness on D3
this Pawn is actually really annoying to
defend
yeah so C3 was one of the only moves
and now this Pawn is basically backwards
not defended by its own pawn and it's on
the alpha and file
very simple plan of
making a battery
maybe eventually making a gun if I can
triple up
it's hard for white to remove the queen
at night C4 I just take it Queen F4 I
take and then win D3
there's a question Eric are you going to
play the World Chess Championship 2023
against Napo
I don't think so unless ding declines
his invitation
and then a lot of other players would
have to decline for me to
be the next in line
so I'd say it's pretty unlikely
but maybe I'll be a photographer
I was a photographer for the last World
Championship match
okay preparing the double up maybe
preparing The Rook lift
Oh no I got forked I have to take
Gangnam at this point I'm guessing we'll
lose 2000
um because Knight C4 I think was played
a little bit too quickly there
maybe it was a fine move
yeah this still takes a lot of work to
win
I'm realizing Queen F5 is coming
a lot of lines
there's a funny line
not sure if it works though causing
rookie six
so if Queen takes it's made uh it's not
mate
almost made King D2 Queen E3 Queen C2
I mean the obvious move is to take
um
and then King takes
smack him with your Rook
I'm trying I'm trying
I I smacked but he smacked back or she
I have no idea where my opponent is
I'll play Rook T8
the smack attack is beginning
yeah I was calculating
getting low on time
my opponent could be over two thousand
resilient offense
I think Rook D7 makes sense here
I mean the structure of favor is white
or D1
played very quickly if I take
yeah I don't want to trade the Queens
though
I have this move
I mean Guinea five is possible
I think the resulting Rook engines
should be still a little bit better for
black
okay rookie six
I'm paranoid that I'm missing something
but I'm not getting mated my queen can't
move here
if Queen H4 I'd win the pawn and trade
Queens
Queen also defends G7
Rook D5 is possible but then after takes
takes takes takes I check and then takes
and if rookie won I play F5
an epon's pinned
if I had to guess right now I'd probably
say like 18
50
it could be higher but there are a few
few moves that
I don't think like high rated players
would play like that Knight T2 move in
the opening and Knight C4 played really
quickly
but it's still not an easy game
when I was in Queen H4
H6
why is this blundered
oh that was a terrible move
this complete blind spot
wow okay
oh we both won we both made really bad
moves back to back
I mean if this was If This Were guess
ELO
and someone was trying to guess my
rating I I probably played like sub
2000
white could have taken with a pawn there
I hope you got my academic paper
oh I don't think I did unless you
emailed it and it went to spam
uh
okay I'll explain what happened after
this game
um I don't know if I can
I really have to like cut my gas a
little bit
opponent can't be 1850 it has to be like
17 Maybe 1600.
but white really survived well
hey it's Lele thank you Lele
welcome
to the Stream
if you're just joining I was playing in
Zen mode I'm trying to guess my
opponent's ELO
yeah I'm guessing maybe 17 20 let's see
1778
okay
that was my best guess so far let's go
um
yeah that was uh not my proudest moment
and probably not my opponent's probably
this moment
so this was a really bad move
because
white can take with a pawn and for some
reason I thought like I just win The
Rook
but after I win The Rook I lose my Rook
and then I'm just down upon
and this move is coming and this is
probably just losing for black
I could have easily been lost
instead my opponent took with a wrong
thing
and then I won The Rook
if we go back
um yeah there's a cool trap here that a
lot of players will walk into
um
it's actually the most common line in
database if white plays King D2 really
cool move Knight H2
and most people take not realizing
what's coming queen E5
uh guaranteed to win
one of the light Rooks in this position
yeah the shift key is next to the caps
lock key so sometimes I'll
accidentally enable caps lock when
trying to make a red arrow or a circle
okay I'm gonna take a small break
and then I'll be back momentarily
uh let me just pause the arena
pause we'll watch the top game
put on some pentatonic
and BRB
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
let's rejoin
Zen mode is staying on
four hours
and about 18 minutes left
hey I'm top thousand twelve tournament
points
a leader has 86
and Zen mode continues
oh should I should I turn off pentatonic
I can't turn off pentatonic without
let's play C5 here
without disabling Zen mode I guess I
could switch tabs though
sound
okay
wait what refresh
okay
okay we have a prediction
[Music]
yeah earlier I said no predictions but
uh I guess we have a prediction where
they're all I'll guess correctly does
this one make sense
um
yeah and I'll like I'll base my
prediction off the
can I played this move immediately
I think I can
off purely the game and not what
whatever people say in chat
hey Eric long time listener first time
Cola what is the best tea oh
I actually
[Music]
um
I was sharing a new Tea Company I
discovered recently
uh
earlier in the Stream
shallow to uproots t.com
uh maybe I'll leave a link in chat
our friendly gifted me the Sentra tea
from them
and it was really good
and they're they're pretty small company
but they work like directly with farmers
in in Asia to
[Music]
um
to produce like really high quality teas
so I'm gonna order more from them
in the very near future
today I'm actually drinking
um I'm not sure where the tea came from
but it was a another gift from a friend
uh some some kind of Oolong tea
from Europe
Play Bishop by five
maybe my Bishop should have gone to F5
in the first place
I'm definitely not playing like a super
Grand Master
because white usually
like if it's a successful London opening
light usually doesn't need to play B3
Bishop D3
okay we'll leave some tension
I think these like these moves are
probably going to be my next moves just
very simple
development
no need to go
too crazy
so it might depend if white disturbs me
in some way
now you have castling then I just
continue with my normal plan
if 95 or if this and I have to
do something a little bit different
I mean I'm happy to see this move
because now
I have two Center pawns and I control a
bit more space in the center
okay Bishop E7
yeah this kind of looks like a reverse
semi-slave
like the idea would be to play A4 and C
or A3 C4
but it's a little bit slow for white
foreign
yeah there's no duck in this game
thankfully
if there was a duck my opponent could
play B4 and duck D6 traffic my Bishop
it's been difficult to like switch
between
duck chess and normal chess
but I guess that's that's part of the
skill of
I guess being a streamer and playing
different variances
to switch between different types of
Chess and
acclimate quickly
so I'm still threatening to take
I think my opponent's just gifting me
the pawn
which makes me believe that my opponent
is
probably rated less than
definitely less than sixteen hundred
maybe less
could be around 1600
I mean London is a very common
beginner's opening and it's also common
like strong player opening
I played I played a lot of viewers who
played London so
trying to gauge like from past
experience
probably say in the range of like 1200
to 1700 there's kind of a wide range
but we'll see how the game progresses
very tempted to leave my knight here
White's not actually threatening to take
it
yeah let's continue
[Music]
some initiative
thank you van of Von zwana or van ziwan
happy seven months
foreign
I'm probably guessing on the lower end
of this reading Spectrum
I I've overguessed so much today I I'm
probably guessing like 1200.
let's see maybe 1250 12.50 let's see
1387 okay
I under guest but not by too much
uh thanks for the game zombodi
oh another game started
ah okay I mean what to do oh I don't
have a Zen mode turned on okay so I told
my opponents great to catch you live
Eric love your content oh
I love you too jazarene
okay I'm playing one game with Zen mode
off because
uh yeah
we don't need to run a prediction
um
yeah let's not
let's not overdue here
okay
that's
I don't know what I did though
okay I'm just gonna focus on the game we
have a ponziani
um D6 is a move
against D6 I actually like to play the
move H3
and the idea is oh no my Pawn
the other idea is that um
yeah this bishop has a hard time
developing
Bishop G4 no longer possible
and then Bishop E6 runs into the fork
I should also mention if if the Knight
were to take I would have D5 Knight
moves and then Queen A4 winning the
other night
but here I should defend the pawn
Bishop D3
it's already a very pleasant position
[Music]
thank you
question from True beerus have you ever
made a video on your worst OTB blunder I
have
which chest streamer do you think
provides the most educational content
that's a tough question it's hard to
single out one streamer specifically
these days are just so many streamers
teaching in their own styles
so yeah that's really hard to say
I guess like I have to give a shout out
to St Louis chess club
because they probably are live
more than most channels
every week every month
doing five to six hours of commentary a
day of like top level tournaments
but um I mean Bishop G5 H6
kind of
I don't know if I wanna
I'm calculating Bishop G5 H6 takes takes
and Knight D5 worse than Queen d8
I've learned so much from you thanks oh
you're welcome thank you too many kins
I don't think I want to play visual G5
because it's not my intention to trade
hi Eric galacta finally catch a stream
love your vids
oh nice catch you crispy Criminal
yeah going back to the question from
True beerus
um
the video on YouTube it's name something
like my worst move or
my worst blunder
it did involve oh no my queen
but not in like the tricky fun way that
I'm used to
maybe at some point like between games I
can uh
I can share that moment
yeah so the point of playing Bishop E3
and then preparing uh Queen D2 is now
each six is no longer possible
and
I can play Bishop G5
safely without
needing to worry about the bishop
getting kicked around
that's a good sign
although okay I don't have Knight D5
I think I'll just play Rook C1
x-ray vision against the queen
generally it's good to align your Rook
with opponent's Queen also good to put
the Rook on a half open vial
A6
that's probably a sign that black
doesn't quite know what to do I'm just
kind of waiting
thinking about Queen F4 but then Knight
H5
so I'm wondering about G4 but then Pawn
H5
foreign
welcome back to all the Ducks
and B5 might be coming
okay I'm gonna play A3 I want to see
what Black's plan is
because the best strategy might just be
to wait and
yeah basically waiting for lock to
self-destruct because now the Knight is
less defended
I'm not sure if I can punish that though
but there's Knights
I mean
take some Knight D5
leaning towards Bishop B1
getting out of the way of the queen also
looking to maneuver to align with the
King
yeah Rooks like to be aligned with the
the puns Queen Bishops like to align
with um component's King
if possible
I think Bishop A2
does allow Knight C4
black was threatening Knight B3 so I
didn't really have time for tactics
there
imros unducky IM Rose and ducky IM Rose
and ducky and Rose and ducky
oh thank you scuba
follow the doggies
oh yeah I think finally the tactics are
about to happen
I just realized too that I just have
Queen F4 in this whole no I didn't
quinoa 4 is now a threat because F7 is
vulnerable
um
yeah it looks like there's a few ways to
just
be crushing here
and the first thing that came to mind is
takes takes Knight here hitting the
bishop and pawn and Bishop d8 runs into
the pork the pin plus the fork
I mean there's also queen of four is
looks nice
I think this is just more concrete
though
and this cleanly wins material
now this night is monstrous and there's
three like pretty big threats here
yeah there's no Rosen trophies in Duck
chess just yet
and she Rose and trophy is only um I
think the site only scans Lee chess
games
don't know if I've had any Rosen
trophies today
I don't think the pork is a real Rosen
trophy
but it's still very satisfying
wait do I even need to I mean Knight V6
is fancy but this is also just
straightforward
this is also just winning
[Music]
um
what's the simplest
it's like do I choose the ice cream the
cake the cookies
I want to eat everything
but it's important not to play with my
food
oh I didn't see that move
so Queen G4 may be coming wow
I think I'll play at this move
just leaving everything hanging I refuse
to capture the vision I refuse to
capture either Rook
I insist on attacking more things
so now F7 the bishop and both books are
hanging
and there's Discovery potential
that looks pretty good
and what I might end up doing is like
take this and then fork or take first to
Fork
oh is there some smothered Uno my queen
Jack maze
also welcome back to Z Nation
the founder of the channel
the only five year subscriber
needs to make a special badge for you
oh we need a pork emote
yeah that's a nice suggestion
not sure how kosher that would be though
okay so I can take the bishop
I'll take the bishop
leaving the Rooks fort
yeah if this were against the ELO
I'd probably under guess a little bit
I guess my opponent tried to play
solidly in the opening and just
kind of fell victim to the eventual
tactics
question from hero of Hasting do you
play panziani In classical OTB games
I used to
um I didn't have a great result with it
but I played it against a handful of
Craft Masters actually over the board
and
I I think my score with it
I'm remembering four games I played with
it all against title players
I lost three of those games
but they weren't really due to the
opening like I think every time I played
ponziani
I got a fine position in the opening
um I played against Savion
in 2015
[Music]
I played it against Grand Master
preachers
from Netherlands
in I think it was 2017 or 2018.
also played against Grandmaster repeat
Martian kanapan
2015.
that was many years ago I played
ponziani OTV
the one game I won with it was actually
against Gary
Grandmaster Gary
uh who has the FM title but um
I think out of all my opponents he
responded like the best to the the
panziani in the opening but it was some
like long and game grind that I
eventually won
okay
um let's just simplify
wouldn't mind the queen trade
also threatening this
yeah I really haven't done like the real
Gus ELO
um maybe I've tried it like a few times
I don't think I've ever made YouTube
content out of it
I find it more enjoyable to like play a
game not knowing the reading of the
opponent
kind of do live guess ELO
oh wow avoiding the queen trade and
preventing this
okay I can take
no mercy here
[Music]
hey thank you aha dress
that's a great twitch username
hola Mis Amigos
I assume that's a Spanish-speaking
Channel
yo Sabe yo
yose
Ave Poco Espanol
pero me espanol no mucho Bueno
bienvenido
Saluda saludos
and uh also good game Bueno partido
okay let me try and stop embarrassing
myself if you're just joining I'm
playing the yearly rapid Arena
um I just won a pretty nice game with
ponziani
opponents got kind of passive
yeah D6 is not the most testing move
um the main line is takes
D5 also playable
and H3 is a Nifty move
and there's a nice trap here that's
a significant number of players fall for
if black takes a poison Pawn
and then D5 Knight moves and then Queen
A4
winning a knight
let me let me switch this
so I've had this position twice on the
chess
there's a lot of different variations of
the Trap too like you could play Bishop
E3 Bishop E3 and that's the same idea
okay let me re-enable Zen mode
hey Eric thanks for the super Chill
Vibes and content hope you win all the
games
oh thank you
oh no my duck chess looking for quack
mate in one
yeah Duchess is taking a break
I know I could press Z but then
sometimes I'll press Z multiple times
and I'll forget if it's enabled or
disabled
if it's between games
so for everyone just joining I'm playing
in Zen mode I don't know my opponent's
rating or name
or standings or how much time is left in
the tournaments
just have to focus on
trying to play some good chess
and we have an English
I could be playing Levy
the very first game of my recent match
with Levy featured this exact opening
and the point is I'm temporarily sacking
upon
uh but it's hard for a way to actually
hold on to the pawn
because this is a kind of a big threat
I think most common white plays D3 D4
also possible
actually D4 is one of the main lines
I remember when I was younger I learned
this line and I thought this was a move
because if takes there's a fork the
problem is Queen A4 and then I'm
actually the one getting forked
so Bishop E7 still Theory
eventually I'll win back upon
I think it's time to take
if life had played Queen B3 earlier
there's Knight D3 but let's take
and this is actually a very positional
structure
uh White has the isolate Queen spawn iqp
but white does control a bit more space
so I have to develop
kind of liking this move
I wouldn't mind more trades like if we
trade everything on D5 then
the pawn actually becomes weaker
and that's generally like a rule about
these positions
um the more trades that happen
the more weak the iso Pawn becomes
I think I'll play C3
or C6
it's so important to control the the
square right in front of the pawn
yeah there's some ideas like Bishop F6
Queen B6 bring the rook in
one long-term idea is to maneuver this
Knight like even though it looks good on
D5
okay I was gonna say sometimes it's
better to go to F5
oh
I overlooked this
I can't take with Queen
I wanted to take take take but my
bishopings
I mean at least I can take with Pawn
oh this is gonna be really symmetrical
though
now the problem structure is almost
completely symmetrical
main difference is that this Pawn is
advanced
another difference to point out though
I gotta defend with pawns
is because we have Bishops of the same
color
it's to my benefit that this Pawn is on
a dark Square
so I have a slightly better Bishop here
we'll see how meaningful it actually is
but I'm pretty sure block is slightly
for choice
I'm not entirely sure how to approach
this position
H5
if I want to win this it's going to take
a lot of patience
probably going to take a blunder
somebody positive vibes through the
internet I appreciate the Positive Vibes
welcome back to Danger cats
I was just looking at this move Queen G4
threatening this and this but it hangs
D5
so it might be better to play this but
that means B7
trying to figure out a way where I can
like play Rook C4 like B5 first
the more I'm looking at B5 the more
sense it makes
it looks like I make just a big hole in
C5 but
the goal is to control C4
and I don't think Rook C5 works because
I can take
after it takes I play D4 hit the bishop
and threaten this
So eventually win the pawn
and it's a good sign that most of
White's pawns are on dark squares
most of my pawns are in light squares
yeah let's play Rook C4 now
and it was a position that looked like
really close to equal
but I think it's like clearly becoming
better for black
I have to be careful not to overestimate
things
but like Rook C8 is a idea
kind of like the prospect of Asics
just so that this pawns over defended my
queen can mobilize
this Rook is super solid
okay those pawns attacked could play
Rook
okay for
also thinking about this move
wait B4 also B4 is just a fork
almost missed this
yeah my opponents
yeah it's hard to guess the rating
because they played like a really solid
opening
probably was close to equal at some
point
blundered this
I mean I have like I was close to
overlooking it
I was so set on keeping my pawns on
light squares
I mean probably guess like 1900.
[Music]
because English is a more sophisticated
opening too
and blunder is happening especially at
that rating level
especially in Rapid shots
okay I'm just trying to simplify
or maybe I'm trying to checkmate
one or the other if white trades Queens
when we simplify if white doesn't trade
Queens then
I'll try and checkmates
so let's start with this
rookie coming
oh thanks so much don't move until you
see it
the four gifted
I'm actually trying to figure out how to
check me here it's like not so
it looks like it should be easy
maybe starting with Queen F3
so I'm threatening Queen D1 with the
triple Fork
and Bishop E3 I likely sacrifice
and then try and take every polling with
check
is it necessary though
oh that's one approach
maybe not the best technique but because
I am leaving white with outside passer
but I think eventually I just I'm gonna
have Queen D1 check
but I'm gonna try and win the other
pawns first
there's a few Spike checks
so thanks for your words pause to
reflect
says thank you for commenting on your
decision
process and reasoning while you play
yeah that's that's one of the goals is
to try and make this a more educational
stream
it is nice to take a small break from
Duck chess and
to try and share some insights into real
chess
I'm debating whether to take this but
let's just keep checking and King here
here I'll take the polymath check
yeah um
oh what ratings I guess
like 19 let's say 1900.
key one
I might like keep
shifting to the right
would you trade a rook or a queen for a
duck
it's hard to place value on the duck
because there's just so much so
different than any other piece where
like it can't be captured and usually
the duck is shared so I don't know how
it would work
if the duck just belonged to me
but it's pretty powerful if it can't be
captured and you can place that anywhere
maybe I would trade a rook for a duck
probably not a queen though
so now I'm guaranteed to take this pong
with Chuck
I might just end up winning all the
Pawns and then White's gonna try and get
stalemated
if King here is actually made in one
the game goes on
okay I think it's time to take
it might be hard to Checkmate just with
the queen defending along the B file
but there's so many ways to win this
in a simple way might just be to force a
queen trade
I'm actually threatening this maybe and
then this and
there's cases where I win the White
Queen
yeah no need to go crazy
Queen defending along the B file beef
yeah not vegetarian friendly
welcome back Stephen Gray
okay so this line I win uh the queen
this queen had a beef with other Queen
okay
um what did I say 1900 let's see 1900
21.04 wow
so
yeah just overlooked a simple Fork
but I think overall it was a nice
positional game like the fact that it
was nearly symmetrical Pawn structure
and the main imbalance was the fact that
this Pawn is on a dark Square
it allowed me to get some nice advantage
and essentially provoked white uh
just kind of self-destruct
you said leave
yeah the TTS doesn't really accentuate
that um
uh real quick let me re-enable Zen mode
analysis board
and we'll just see the opening just to
demonstrate this is a line that's been
played
I've played a handful of times before I
have a good score with
um it's been played at the top level too
now I'm pretty sure this line has just
refuted actually like if White's really
prepared with engine the scheme between
ivankuk and Fiddler
uh ivanchuk just completely refuted this
opening
and the move to play is Knight F3 I
believe
but it's
it's risky to play because after Knight
D3 white loses casting rights has to
Bongo
area loading engine yeah even stockfish
can't really figure out this position
[Music]
but if you go deep enough I'm pretty
sure White's doing quite well
what was the force made after King A2 oh
King A2 is dubious
oh Maiden six
did the engine just break just broke I
wonder if that's because of my local
reducer CPUs
maybe this is just
the chest overlords trying to force me
to find the maiden six
I mean I assume it's Queen A1 King
you're you're the salt forcing we gotta
take the queen here and then
how many more moves we have
and then here
and then here and then here and then
here
that's six that's probably already six
moves though
maybe we'll never know
let your refresh
I've never seen the engine break like
this
okay so let's see the main six Queen B
one take the queen
take the pawn bait in three from this
position really
there's only one Maiden three Queen C4
King A3
ah Queen B5 nice
forcing King A2 and then checkmate
okay let's move on
so far I'm undefeated
I've had a nice variety of openings
gradually working my way up
there's three and a half hours left in
this tournament
I'm not sure if I'll play the whole
thing but I'm trying to just have good
quality games
should I Zen mode berserk what do people
think
let's do a quick poll
Zen mode berserk yes no
I have not berserked yet this tournament
wow 19-1
37 okay I guess always hurt then
it's risky though because I might be
playing against a strong player
oh opponent was working back I wonder if
my opponent's watching the Stream
okay we're just playing a Blitz game now
okay
interesting
opponent has to be watching it seems
like they're just messing with me what
is this
and this could be a high rated player
but it also could just be what is this
what's this opening
there's no way I'm playing a strong
player unless I'm playing Magnus and
he's just trolling this is something
Magnus would maybe do
what is this opening I've never seen
this before if someone is defended
because Bishop E3
foreign
oh it's so funny
how do I how do I attack
Queen D3
I have such a large space advantage
I think I'll just Castle
do I wanna trade I don't think I want to
trade
my phone's playing so quickly
I've only used eight seconds off the
clock
but no mercy here
black has violated so many opening
principles
it's time to pay
man look look at this whole
D6 is just an orifice and
blocks Home looks like opponent is
playing chess 960.
[Music]
they despise normal chess so much
they have to turn it into chess 960.
I take this
I think I'll just play this patient move
this could be a really strong player
this could also be a complete beginner
who just is
messing around
it's so hard to guess a reading actually
but they're playing quickly so they have
to be like decently
like a decent player
debating whether to take with Pawn or
I should think I should take with
knights
look at this giggle horsey
it's so Majestic
I mean queen queen G6 it's just full
domination
[Music]
got a giggle horsey Giga Queen
Giga pin
no mercy now
uh
uh oh no my Rook
hey
You're Just in Time checkmate
okay
uh that was a funny a funny game what do
I guess our reading next
it I mean a point probably played like
at the level of 1100 but
the fact that they move so quickly and
they seem so confident
I think I'll I'll say like 1700. let's
see
okay 1626. not a bad guess
I'm just curious if my opponent's
accuracy of this game
also yeah I think again for the raid the
well-heeled king
of
[Music]
72 accuracy
but 108 Cent upon laws
is that game going on
oh on YouTube or in this whole stream
might go on YouTube
shout out to everyone watching in the
future on YouTube
if you've made it this far
leave a smiley face in the comments
also like the video and subscribe
it helps me feed my family
okay top 240.
oh no no longer a top 240.
top 241.
yeah leechas recently introduced
accuracy
not too long ago there is some article
explaining how they calculate it
but I'll have to
have to actually look at it because I'm
not sure how it works
um
okay all berserk again because
so many people wanted me to Zen mode
berserk
oh a Point Missouri back
so two double berserks in a row
I saw some offhand comment earlier
asking for a Smith Mora so
whoever was asking for that
I hope
I'm putting a smile on your face
this is one of the main lines
opponent seems preparing
I could be playing a strong player here
this might be some Theory G5 really
I really want to play this move
that seems so reckless
but also so fun
um
I'm considering it
I'm trying to weigh the pros and cons
I'm gonna do it oh no my Bishop
now usually a decision like this I would
take into account my opponent's rating
but I don't know what my opponents rated
against a stronger player I probably
wouldn't play this move
against anyone
less than like 1700 I'd probably play
this move
I like the fact my bones thinking
I'm curious if like G5 was still opening
prep from them
um this is hard to explain
but the point is whatever it takes I
take back with pong I can pre-move this
and then the file will open
there are lines where I lose a bishop
wow
so I win back
oh I'm gonna be down two Pawns
that seems okay though
I don't need to take the Knight I
probably should take the Knight
okay so what just happened
I'm down two Pawns
but opponent chose not to win the piece
which is kind of interesting
and now
I am I think the bishop King is kind of
stuck in the center
the center might be the safest place for
the king because both sides are kind of
in shambles
of course there's this idea
but if Rook G8 I'm in time to maybe take
maybe play F3
and black is underdeveloped here I mean
this is the only developed piece
these things have not moved yet
okay I still need to develop my Rooks
but these pieces are in good position
welcome back to teotaki
and cl Smith
shout out to CL Smith
has been
streaming on YouTube recently
um I wish there was a twitch command to
give a YouTube shout out
I take
do people hear that
I have noise suppression
do people hear that now
there's ambulances outside
but they're kind of in the distance
anyway I should focus getting so
distracted I have three visual C5 King
H1
ah there's some H3 idea
I don't want to take because
what can I take and then take on E6
wow that's a funny line so take take
take
Queen E7 Queen H5
take rookie one and if takes I take and
hit the Rook I think that's okay
someone call an ambulance
actually someone already called an
ambulance but it wasn't for me
thankfully
also thank you awkward nights
yeah so Queen H5 is just a really nice
resource here
painting the pawn ensuring that the pawn
can't take and if the queen takes
I'm winning the queen
surprisingly my opponents just allowed
that
I'm still guessing over 2000
but somehow this was yeah this is
working out really nicely
hitting the rook and the pawn
Yeah clean up on file h
preventing Rook D2
on Rook D2 Queen h70 also
now do I take on each four
I don't think there's a need just work
off one
I still have to move quickly
realizing this is some resource
yeah the pawns hanging so Rook h8
expected
H3
uh ricka for his idea
of this move
hitting the bishop and Rook
Rook C2 Queen H7 Forks
if Rook C3 probably this move
oh that Fork's a king
some reason I didn't realize I was
attacking the king
okay uh the opening
speed and preparation was kind of
impressive
so I'll guess like 21.50
let's see
22.50 okay 100 points off
yeah I mean this this is one of like the
main
like reputable approaches to Smith Mora
as far as I know
I wonder what asterman plays against
this
engine says box better
[Music]
oh G5 maybe it was still prep
I played Knight T5 here which is the
second engine move but
uh considered a blunder
so first of all if Pontius Bishop
there's some other mates
not even some other duck mates just
normal smothered mates
opponent took which is also good Pawn
digs is the best I mean I was gonna be
okay playing this position
[Music]
because already after Pawn takes Knight
takes
oh Knight T4
okay so I guess I would take first
I was just envisioning the Knight
getting to D6 somehow
seven also targets
okay
hey we have a CL command
thanks Josh
shout out to Josh too we also have a
Josh command
I'm gonna take another break
it's break time oh no okay I'm not
taking a break
playing another game
try berserk
I guess I'll berserk I won't spers
okay it's turning into some Blitz
um
I'll play a different line than what I
played earlier
but it's kind of similar
okay maybe kind of different
uh yeah let's take
so this is a reverse Grand Prix attack
normally an opening that you play as
Wild against Sicilian
but this is basically reverse the
ceiling into
and it's a fun one for Blitz because the
plans are very simple
there's some plan to attack
there's another plan to play very
positionally on the queen side
not just blunder just a lot of this
don't know what's happening after that
move actually
Queen A4 Knight D4 wow
this is a semi-bluff
okay D4 is a good sign so I have time to
make sure things are stable
there's no idea Knight A5 and pawn C5
it was actually a very common positional
plan
in this opening
if I can fix uh doll pawns as they are
it can be very unpleasant for whites
and yeah the problem with uh this
position which I've noticed for a lot of
players
on the white side it can be very hard to
find a clear plan and for Vlog there's
just so many ways to keep improving
and already I think I'm winning a pawn
not sure if I need to take it like so
soon
like Rook goes back if I take there's
Queen B3
[Music]
Bishop E6 Pawn D5
oh in that line I do have Knight D2
I have to take first
so now the file's open
we might see Bishop D5 check
online trading Bishops I mean if takes
takes then the queen and Rook are both
hanging
rook's gonna have to move away and then
I probably take the pawn
Now The Bishop's no longer sufficiently
defended it's attacked twice
and pinned and white can get out of it
but
then I hit the queen and I'll be
threatening the fork
oh fancy move
so if I take there's takes
I'm actually not sure if I want to take
the queen here
it seems more fun to take the bishop
because I'm I'm still up a pawn
and on top of that light's a little bit
paralyzed
the queen
and queen D6
I think I'm eventually winning material
too
the pin is
really really nice for black
and what does white do
Rook B2 is probably
um
a decent try
preventing Queen D2
I mean I could take the Rook but I don't
know if I want to take the Rook
um
yeah I'm gonna go for the attack The
Rook is still trapped anyway
I just want to play F3 and queen
basically F3 and queen G2 mate
of course I have to legally get to G2
I'm guessing the rating between
like 18 Maybe
a little bit less than 1800
they berserked back though
maybe around 1800
I mean this game is one of those cases
where an opponent kind of just stumbled
into
a really unpleasant position
this POG is really nice I could have
played this in this but
I'm trying to create mating ideas
there's a funny thread of Rook B2
okay
I was still inclined to play Rook B2
there
okay let's go to 1800.
1919. I feel like my guessing is getting
better
like the first few games I was off by
so many hundreds of points
I was playing SpongeBob
[Music]
good luck smile
oh thank you
barbariance
happy two months
Oh I thought I had Sun mode turned on
but I guess not
okay
well I know my opponent
nobody's working I'm gonna play uh just
a normal rapping game this time
and I don't know if I play the London
yet today
this might be my first London of today
I gotta have at least one
this is my bread and butter opening
yeah so with B6 so soon
it's playing this move recently in some
like title Tuesdays
and I'll combine it with
this is a sign that black wants to play
94.
I'm actually wondering like if it makes
sense to play H5
maybe H5 as soon as possible
I have a very similar position recently
against like some decently strong GM
entitled to the
and there's some idea to move the queen
to G3
I mean maybe I can start with Queen G3
I think I should start a C3 though
eventually I want to play Queen G3
and this approach of like moving the H
Pawn early and playing queen of three
it's a very modern type of approach in
the London
and this really only works against
certain move orders
but this early B6 move order is is one
of the lines where
at least the engine will suggest the
early H Pawn push
and yeah now I'm inclined to take and
then play Queen G3
threatening to take on each six
if Queen F6 her son naichi IV
we might see takes
maybe bishop takes
that looks good
opponent's moving pretty quickly so
as you keep Pace I don't want to
overthink things
I don't think I'm gonna win the
tournament I think I'm I'm a little bit
far behind I didn't late join a few
hours late
but um maybe I'll finish top 100.
the goal is just to play instructive
chess
teach something from every game
oh there's a big Scrabble tournament
tomorrow
that actually sounds fun
I've been playing more Scrabble recently
I just play against a bot
like if I can't sleep
I'll play
not histibot but the level below
hastybot
shout out to Google's
I was playing
um I was playing Scrabble I think it was
yesterday
and the bot play the
a seven-letter word pawnage
like P like pawn and then a g e
and I didn't realize that was even a
word
because there's this like term Ownage
like getting owned
or like pwn like get pwned
not sure how to pronounce it though
if there were Scrabble titles would you
try to get one
I think there are right
like Josh recently became a Scrabble
master
but I think it's more based on
percentile
as the goal of mine to compete in an
over-the-board Scrabble tournament
I mean hopefully sometime
within the next year maybe I'll compete
in some online tournaments too
oh pawnage
an act of potting
have I done some pawnage this game
there's been many acts uponing
Seattle Smith says my Pawn age is Young
but they're very mature for their age
what about my queenage
oh no my queenage I want to take but
then F6 is actually really annoying
because F6 not only defends G7 but
attacks a pinned Knight
I don't think I can get away with that
another idea is to take here
which leads to craziness
there's actually a really crazy line
wait okay let's draw some arrows so
Knight F7
if anything takes back on the seven I
win D6 and I think I'm happy
the issue is Bishop takes F4
but then they have the intermediate
Knight H6
attacking the king the pawn is pinned
and the bishop is pinned to the queen so
nothing can take the Knight
king would have to move
like King I take
yeah then the lights just misplaced
don't think that works
another idea is to take here
actually a cool idea if Queen takes off
Knight t7
90s uh there is Bishop F4
I was thinking 97 Bishop D6
like there's so many potential tactics
here
I'm trying to figure out what can
potentially work
I have another like really crazy idea of
sacking a piece
of actually going for this allowing F6
and then just moving back
and then in the event of takes
takes
Bishop E7 H6
and how does black defend
I mean all of that might just be
unnecessary
everything looks so fun though
it's like Disney World but I have to
choose a ride that doesn't hurt me
uh Bishop H6
there's also this move too
I'm realizing I just have to rely on
intuition
another idea is to play Bishop C4 and
just develop like a normal person
and that might be what I choose
but then no then there's takes
uh takes and then
wait takes here
I can safely take back actually
because take six I threatened mates
but there's a bishop B4
crazy lines here
I'm gonna play Bishops before
I'm trying to set up this
move Bishop H6
and intuitively I think this is a fine
move as well
developing but
yeah this is a small issue
I think I just
take back
I'm inclined to take this way
it does expose the king a little bit
but I don't think this move is too
powerful because King F1
that's a move but now I take
although I played this so quickly but
there's no way this can be good
I think I just take
ah there's Bishop takes and queen takes
I gotta move quicker
takes takes ticks
okay an event of Bishop takes in Queen
takes I play this
I think it's okay
there are variations where I lose a pawn
I'm currently up upon but black wins
back this pawn and then maybe this Pawn
but I think I'm gonna have a lot of
attack
I can't take the queen because then both
Bishops hang so I have to play this
affecting this or this
if Queen here I I bong cloud
and then I'd have to get the Rook into
play
okay that move I wasn't expecting as
much because now I have casting
now the king's completely safe and I
have
some attack
but I am down the pond so
short game so far
I'd love to see this move to have Bishop
E5
it's nice having the pollen ready to
come to H6
I think Rook C1
to move a lot quicker
I mean the goal is to remove the Knight
and play Bishop B5
if Queen F5 I probably played Bishop E2
got that move I did not consider
this move
I really want to play this
taking H7
I think I'll start with this
this move opens up some different ideas
I mean first of all it's a pawn so
Bishop D5 is actually a major blow
to Block's whole position because this
is a threat and this is a threat
good luck Eric Kim Rose and let's go oh
thank you madzer welcome back
I think I'm in good shape now
very tense position though
a lot of tricky lines to figure out
there
and black can still survive
okay never mind
I think it's possible my opponent just
didn't realize that Queen also targeted
E4
foreign
I guess if Queen D7 I play Queen E4 and
hit this
so now I'm up
Queen for a night
plenty of time
I'll bring the rook in
queen wants to infiltrates
as well as a rook
no mercy
okay
um I should Analyze This
because I'm not sure like this was a
critical moment after Queen C7
and it's a position I should
really know what to do because it's such
a common type of situation
engine says Bishop H6
although at higher depth
okay still Bishop H6 so
how does this work
H4
that's not easy to spot
and if takes
Bishop Bishop G7 law
Rook G4 coming
that's crazy
ah now here Bishop C4
yeah it's kind of a computer line
you want to see after King H6
was that later in the game
I'm not sure when that was
possible
I'm curious about the opening
ah Queen G3 immediately is strong
and if Queen
ah what is 98
takes and then here
ah wow H6 coming
along where I took on F7
with a knight
oh it's like um
what line was that though I'm already
forgetting
oh is this line oh I was calculating
this
yeah this doesn't quite work because
after
Bishop F4 96 King H7
oh not King H7 but King h8
and then
yeah the knights was a bit misplaced it
looks cool at first
but white just runs out of steam
okay
I'm re-enabling Zen mode Zen mode should
be back on now
I appreciate you keep doing what you do
I appreciate you too
you no soy chorizo
solving with prime for six months
yeah friendly reminder if you want to be
appreciated even more
you can sub with prime if you have Prime
easy ways to support the channel
um you just have to link your your
Amazon Prime account
and look for the free sub button
multipleserk and let's play maybe a
different opening
idea to
actually let's play Budapest
idea to be aggressive
I could be playing a stronger opponent
here this could be really risky
I'm actually playing into a funny Gambit
that I had recently
if takes I play Queen D4 attacking
almost all the things
yeah this could get wild very quickly
I had this position once in an over the
board game
I'll have to dig up that game it might
be like in my shoebox
of old score sheets
but I remember
getting this exact position after Knight
takes E5 I played Queen D4
and then my opponent defended everything
with Knight T3
as a funny position I think in that game
I took on F2
ends up winning
I went through a brief phase of playing
The Budapest
OTV
um around when I was like 2100
go back in like 2008 2009
and White's taking time here
there's not too many options
there's Bishop takes there's Knight
takes there's Bishop G3
Bishop G3 I probably played D5
oh wow there's H3
so I could take on F2
I don't know the strength of my opponent
I don't think H3 is a good move though
okay I have this move
it's important to defend the bishop and
defend my king
so the rooksville attacks
and if takes takes and I'm hitting the
Knight twice
on top of that the dark's first could be
very weak
oh you witnessed a smothered OTB mates
oh in The Budapest
yeah there's a classic smothered Meats
Budapest trap
speaking of chutneys I feel really close
to mating here
it takes more work though
I'll play this move preventing the E4
also preparing this
Jack
oh there's a funny line
it's gonna happen though
um
I got a castle first there's a really
funny line though
my Bishop oh no
someone call an ambulance
oh wait the Knight can take
uh oh someone actually call an ambulance
and then take
oops
I just left too many things hanging
my opponent's probably busy calling an
ambulance
oh
but not for me
that's so unsatisfying though
oh I was I I wanted to end the game with
this and then a funny smother means
the fork checkmate
also if Knight takes
um I have this Checkmate there's there's
a few mating ideas here
it's actually kind of cool
I'm not sure if there's a defense for
whites maybe like E3 or E4 is the best
move
it's funny because like the the classic
Budapest trap line
um feature is a very similar idea
and a bit more simplified position
[Music]
but uh it's essentially the same thing
and take the bishop and then some other
remains I'll show it real quick
I assume that's what teotwagi was
referring to
I showed this once in the St Louis chess
club lecture a net of three
was it Knight C6 Bishop here Bishop
check D2
and in this position
you take the pawn and you say oh no my
Bishop
and then you smothermate
anyway Queen H4 not mate
oh Queen H4 mate next move Queen G3
means
okay I think we'll end it with that one
that was a nice finish
I forgot to guess my opponent's reading
my point was 2418.
I I would have I would have guessed Sub
2000 there
um
my point was that was the highest rated
opponent I played this tournament
and I think that was my shortest game
this tournament
they resigned after 14 moves
oh okay we'll end it with that I'm kind
of tired
um It's Time reviewed
assuming this whole video goes on
YouTube shout out to everyone watching
in the future on YouTube
uh big things if you made it all the way
through the video
let me know your favorite game let me
know what you learned in the comments
um feel free to leave timestamps of your
favorite moments
and be sure to watch on Twitch
subscribe on Twitch
and
stay tuned for more content
and say hi to Twitch chat too yeah
twitch chat says hi YouTube